منذ انطلاقه عرضه في ديسمبر الماضيه حقق
الفيلم السعودي ستار عوده محمد الاسطوري
عائدات عاليه ونجح في تصدر قائمه الافلام
السعوديه من حيث المبيعات نجح الفيلم في
التفوق على الفيلم العالمي افاتار والعديد
من الافلام العربيه والعالميه بالاضافه
الى التفاعل القوي على كافه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عرض الفيلم العائلي ستار عوده
محمد الاسطوري سيبدا في كافه الدور العرض
بدور الخميس انطلاقا من اليوم الخميس
1923 الفيلم الكوميدي والاكشن يحكي قصه
فرصه رائعه تلوح امام الشاب سعد ليحقق
حلمه ويصبح احد نجوم المصارعه لكن الحلم
سرعان ما يتحول الى كابوس وهو من بطوله
ابراهيم الحجاج عبد العزيز الشهري ابراهيم
خير الله وشاهد الكفاري ومن اخراج عبد
الله
سعودي سعودي
[موسيقى]
من الكويت
2016 يسعد صباحك يا ابراهيم شكرا على
تواجدك معنا في صباح العربيه منورنا اهلا
بك
يا هلا يسعد صباحكم يا هلا ومرحبا صباح
الخير اهلا وسهلا
السعوديه حدثنا اكثر عن فكره الفيلم
[موسيقى]
اكثر فيها خصوصا الوحده الان لنا تقريبا
يعني هم عالم السينما العالم جديد علي
بالنسبه
الثاني
بصراحه احنا مو يعني مو متفاجئين من رده
فعل الناس بالعكس
لكل اللي كانوا معانا من رحلتنا في
الانترنت والان في رحلتنا الجديده في
السلامه
وفي عطله في نهايه الاسبوع اتصدر شو بدك
تذاكر السعوديه وتفوق على الفيلم
الجمهور السعودي يعني شو السر
طيب احنا في رحلتنا الحين في بدايتنا
اكتشفنا انه في ناس محتاجه تشوف فلم
يشبهها فيلم يمثلها فيلم تشوف نفسها في
يعني اعتبرت السينما الكبيره عباره عن
المرايه لها تشوف فيها صوت سعودي يتكلم
نفس لهجتها بنفس الوقت واحنا اللي طابع
كوميدي يمكن ما تعودوا عليه الكون اصلا
موجود في السينما فيلم سعودي
فاعتقد الناس الناس
عطلت نهايه الاسبوع
الجو تمام عند شغله عن حياته عن كل شيء
يكون محيط فيه
اللي حققها في المسطار يعني حتى اليوم الى
اما ده تعكس قدره الفيلم السعودي على
المنافسه بقوه محليا وعلاميه ولجهه كذلك
الجوده الانتاج والجوده الاخراج انت ممثل
ومنتج هذا الفيلم حدثنا اكثر عن خبرتك
فيها
يعني الان احنا زي ما اتفضته في التقرير
احنا ماشيين مستمرين في الجوله في همم في
السعوديه ومستمرين الان في الخليل الى 19
من الكويت قطر الامارات البحرين وعمان
ولسه الرحله مستمر همم
تقدر تشوفيني كل اسبوع ابديت سلام
السينمات تبدا تطلب فبشرك من بعد الجسم في
عندنا رحله الى
لندن بعدها الى امريكا ان شاء الله فيها
في ركوست قاعده تيجي هذا شيء سعيد جدا انا
فيما يقعد يفاجئونا في ناس بدنا السينما
في اللي تبدا تسوي الكويست بناء على طلب
ال ال الناس مع السوشيال ميديا صارت تواصل
معاهم اسرع
اول ما بدينا في السعوديه فقط اول اسبوعين
بدينا نلحق السوشيال ميديا الكويت يقولون
اوكي
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
التفاعل كبير من الجمهور مع هذه الحمله
الدعائيه
بصراحه انا شفت نعمه شلل الشباب يروحوا مع
بعض او بنات يروحوا مع بعض او عائله تروح
مع بعض
شيء مره سعيد مره فخورين فيك
ترضي ناس تكون تشبههم تكون قريب من قصصهم
تكون جزء من الواقع اللي فيه والباقي راح
يجيء توفيق من الله اكيد يعني وهذا اللي
احنا ناوي
جدا
همم اغنيه لازم تفوز وشيله 16 يعني كيف
شفته تفاعل جمهور كبير
احنا طبعا سوينا بينج باركوا دراسه للي
موجود في السينما العربيه
ولاحظنا ان في افلام كثيره تستخدم الاغاني
والصوت يعني انت ما لازم بس تمتعني بصريا
لازم تعني سمعيا عشان اتحرك من بيتي واروح
لبس
وهذه الاستراتيجيه اللي سويناها لازم يكون
الفيلم ممتعب غنائيا وممتع برده نفس بصريه
فلذلك في بشيء مصاحب للفيلم راح ينزل قريب
وهو قلبه هذا الشيء اللي تستخدمونه في
هولي والتمام
[موسيقى]
الاغنيه تسمع كل شيء محيط لهذا انت تشتغل
3 60
سينما انت لا تكون معه في السوشيال ميدي
تكون معه في السياره وفي القنوات السمعيه
لازم تكون
كل المتابع في كل اي مسيره ممكن يلمسها او
يشوفها او يسمع لذلك اعتقد هذه بالاسباب
بالخلطات اللي لازم تكون متوفره في الفيلم
عشان توصل لشريحه اكبر من الوجود
تحقيق سطار اعلى الارادات في تاريخ
السينما السعوديه ونتمنى لكم النجاح يا
ابراهيم كممثل ممثل 2016